Do you know a peter parker who's spider-man yes is
that him no is that him no is that him no is that
him no is that him no is that him yes Welcome back
everyone this will be my full spider-man no way
home breakdown video easter eggs for the entire
movie how it connects with all the other marvel
phase 4 movies and what it's setting up there's a
bunch of teasers for future marvel phase 4 movies
as well as spider-man 4 in the next spider-man
trilogy too so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
still a bunch of things that we have to talk about
careful for spoilers for the entire movie if you
have not seen it yet but the opening scene of the
movie starts during the spider-man far from home
post-credits scene you get the audio of that scene
playing over the marvel studios logo the sony logo
then the first actual frame is mysterio shouting
out peter parker's identity as spider-man and
their immediate reaction before the crowd starts
to mob mj and spider-man has to go save her love
how the dude totally tries to tackle spider-man as
he's taking off like he had a chance some of
you may have also spotted a continuity error
during this scene too so if you look at mj she's
wearing the same outfit that she was at the end of
spiderman far from home in the post-credits scene
but the continuity heir is actually the black
dahlia necklace so she's not wearing the necklace
during the far from home post-credit scene but she
is wearing it here because they broke it during
spider-man far from home so it's not quite an 8
years later homecoming level air but it is like a
minor continuity error she wears the black dahlia
necklace through the entire movie and after the
second spell just a tease that she will eventually
remember spider-man like she won't remember why
the necklace is important to her like why am i
always wearing this it's important for some reason
i just can't remember exactly where i got it
you can see them web sling past an ad for the
rogers captain america musical which we've seen
during the hawkeye series this movie just to
explain the timeline overlaps a little with the
events of the hawkeye episodes the beginning
of the movie takes place right at the end of
the summer 2024 after they come back from their
summer vacation trip but most of the plot takes
place around october around the halloween holiday
everything right up to the final battle with the
green goblin mostly takes place over the course
of a couple days though there are a couple small
time jumps right at the beginning of the film but
once the sinister six characters show up they're
only in the mcu along with anDoctorew garfield and
Tobey maguire spider-man for a little over a day
like they're not actually in the mcu for that long
but at the end of the film after doctor strange
performs his second spell there's another time
jump and everybody forgets peter parker entirely
they pick up months later during the christmas
holiday because you can see it's snowing
everywhere their christmas decorations everywhere
in the hawkeye crossover actually goes a little
bit deeper too at the very end of the movie when
they reveal his brand new spider-man costume
the bright blue in red comic book accurate costume
and he web slings through rockefeller center past
the ice rink and the christmas tree we're actually
going to see one of the big final battles take
place on the hawkeye series with yelena belova
in the tracksuits there next week in hawkeye
episode 6. they swing past a fortnight ad which
will remind you of new master and avengers end
game there's also a sony playstation ad because
sony owns the spider-man rights so in all the
spider-man movies there are ads for all kinds of
sony products there's a second ad for the rogers
captain america musical the ads are all over new
york city in the hawkeye series as well they can
do this all day when they come out of the subway
tunnels it's right in front of mr delmar's bodega
his newest bodega because they blew it up during
spider-man homecoming we find out that happy and
ought may have just broken up i think mostly just
to pay off their dramatic arc because of what's
happening with aunt may dying at the end of the
movie but this is the same apartment that they
were living in during spiderman far from home
so if you look around his beDoctoroom you can
see the closet where he keeps his original stark
tech spider-man suit the advanced suit that's
the newer steve ditko red and black suit and in
the corner he's got the case for the iron spider
nanotech suit plugged in on the wall it says don't
turn off the lights because if you unplug this it
disables the nanobots but it's also meant to be
an easter egg for spider-man turn off the dark
the spider-man broadway play from a couple years
ago so now we have a spider-man musical and we
have a captain america musical the t-shirt that
he puts on is the same t-shirt that he wore during
spider-man homecoming i survived my trip to new
york city they have a joke about j jonah jameson
broadcasting from his house with a green screen
like he's some common youtuber they show a bunch
of artwork and signs people carry depicting peter
as the devil calling him the devil in disguise
this is just a reference to the mephisto storyline
from spiderman one more day which inspired some of
the story aspects about doctor strange's spell
in the movie to make people forget that he was
spider-man during that storyline the reason peter
asked doctor strange to make everyone forget
was to try and bring aunt may back to life
after she was killed she also dies in this movie
but doctor strange flat out turns him down and
mephisto takes advantage of him saying that i'll
help you perform the spell when they show their
lineup peter's mugshot number is zero seven
one five zero zero that's a reference to ultimate
spider-man number 15 which was released in the
year 2000 it was a story where someone figures
out his secret identity and wants to reveal it
to the world just like mysterio did in the movie
the artwork of the baby spider crying in diapers
on the cover of the time magazine is done kind of
in the style of the spider ham art from spider-man
into the spider burst and we see someone throw
green paint on his advanced suit in the street
which is why later in the movie he turns the
advanced suit inside out and that's where
the black suit comes from so if you couldn't
tell the black suit is just the advanced suit
reversed inside out when charlie cox's matt
murdock daredevil shows up and they start talking
about stolen stark tech they're talking about
the fabricator in the arc reactor that he joined
so just to explain the daredevil of it all now
charlie cox's daredevil from the netflix series
is canon to the mcu they just reintroduced vincent
d'onofrio's kingpin during the hawkeye series so
kingpin is also candid to the mcu now i've already
done a bunch of videos about what their plans are
for daredevil inside the mcu eventually they are
going to do a daredevil disney plus series but
we probably won't see that for a couple years
peter parker does not know that matt murdock
is daredevil that's why he's surprised when
he catches the brick and says wait a minute
how did you do that and he says i'm a very good
lawyer i believe we will also see charlie cox show
up during the she-hulk episodes early next year
when that series premieres the agent who arrests
spider-man is named cleary that's a version of
comic book clery from the damage control comic
book damage control in the mcu is an agency
created by iron man in partnership with the us
government to help clean up the damage caused
by the avengers battles superhero battles in
general they've since become a full branch of the
us government like homeland security so that's why
they're able to arrest spider-man and everyone
else when they're taking all these pictures for
their evidence there's a bunch of easter eggs and
callbacks of spider-man homecoming peter's star
wars toys he has a picture with ned lee's the
star tech glasses that control the Doctorones
with the edith ai spider-man's new t-shirt says
the physics are theoretical but the fun is real
because he's always wearing joke t-shirts through
the movies during the interrogation we learned
that spider-man still hasn't figured out about
talos and his wife being the scroll versions
of nick fury and maria hill real nick fury will
be back during the secret invasion disney plus
series next year for those of you with a bunch of
scroll theories the picture they show of happy on
the screen with the huge mullet is actually from
iron man 3 in the flashback at the beginning of
the movie to the 90s and one of the other funny
meta easter eggs some of you probably realized is
that when they're having the charlie cox daredevil
cameo scene is the way he and happy go back and
forth because if you don't remember during the
ben affleck daredevil movie john favreau played
foggy nelson so there's like this weird multiverse
daredevil thing going on between them we then find
out happy's apartment is on long island he's got
all kinds of stark ted easter eggs iron man easter
eggs all over the place he's got iron man's dumb
e robot when they reveal the fabricator from far
from home the ark reactor powering it is iron
man's old mark vi reactor that he made using the
new infinity stone element during iron man 2.
this is also the arc reactor that he was using
during the first avengers movie when he and mj
are talking on the phone you notice behind her in
her beDoctoroom walls you can see the Doctorawings
that she did to peter when they were in detention
during homecoming and the next day at school when
the crowd is waiting for them betty brant uses the
trademark mary jane catchphrase from the comics
go get em tiger if you follow the spider-man no
way home account on tick tock to they made her
a full-blown daily bugle intern for jay jonah
jameson in universe and she runs the daily bugles
tick-tock account the crowd shouts all kinds of
jokes at them one of the dudes is a total mj stan
and asks her if she's going to have his spider
babies in the comics she literally has a baby with
peter parker who gets his spiderman abilities and
they name her mae parker after aunt may she's
called mayday parker and becomes a version of
spider-man when she gets older later in the movie
when Tobey maguire spider-man shows up he reveals
that he's started a family with his mj so it's
possible that they also have a daughter mayday
parker style in his universe flash thompson's book
flashpoint is also a clever reference at the dc
comics flash story flashpoint where he tries to
change the past to undo the death of his mother
but it makes everything so much worse and when
mr harrington mr dell and coach wilson unveil
the shrine that they created to spider-man you
can see a whole bunch of objects from spider-man
homecoming like his debate team jacket there's
a real-life spider-man action figure legit like
it's just a regular spider-man action figure
that you go out on the street and buy it's of
him wearing his classic comic book costume which
we then later see tom hall and spider-man create
at the end of this movie the way they're playing
coach wilson though is that like he's a full-blown
conspiracy nutter who totally believes mysterio's
video on the rooftop steve ditko's name is written
in graffiti in the background also you see genki's
name written here ned leeds in the mcu is kind
of a combination of ned leads from the comics and
genki from the ultimate spider-man comics they're
all trying to get into mit because midtown high is
a stem school like it feeds into the sciences also
his surrogate father in the mcu iron man went to
mit mit is also the place where iron man gave his
big civil war presentation on the barf technology
so mit is just a big mcu location in general
when he starts getting the college acceptance
letters you can see that he started putting
together his lego death star again from spider-man
homecoming you also see the lego palpatine from
homecoming as well the dummy robot later knocks it
over destroying it and later electro asks him are
these your legos in the movie mj is working at a
diner just like kirsten dunst's mj was working at
a diner during the Tobey maguire spider-man movies
is a different diner but just another subtle
reference between their versions of the character
when he goes to the sanctum the reason the door
opens automatically is because wong already knows
that he's there like he can sense him outside
the door they explain the reason the sanctum is
covered in snow is just because of the confusion
between wong and doctor strange and what their
relationship is now post avengers endgame and
their new duties because one of the main gateways
in the sanctum connects to siberia and they didn't
block the snow that comes through siberia also
being where the hyDoctora winter soldier program
is located and they explained that because
doctor strange was snapped for five years wong
automatically inherited the title of sorcerer's
supreme and they didn't take it away from him
after avengers end game when doctor strange came
back so they're kind of bickering like this old
married couple about who's really in charge
like uh technically wong is in charge and they
kind of play it as a joke throughout the film like
whatever happens don't let wang find out wong also
jokes that had doctor strange been the one for the
past five years who was still around and didn't
get snapped he would have probably burnt the
sanctum to the ground that's also kind of meant to
be one of the setup teasers for the plot of doctor
strange to where we see the consequences of doctor
strange messing with reality in the multiverse
i'll be doing a separate doctor strange 2 trailer
video because there is so much stuff going on in
that trailer just to explain the timeline of this
movie too this is taking place after the events of
the shangshi movie so he's already had his scene
fighting with the abomination in the ring and
i'll talk about this at the end of the video too
because of so many crazy things happening in the
mcu all right on top of each other the events of
the eternals movie is also taking place around the
same time the events of spiderman no way home are
taking place when doctor strange shows up he's
wearing a columbia sweater because that's where
he went to college it's also a subtle easter egg
for the tobey maguire spider-man movies because in
real life they use the campus of columbia in new
york city to double as the campus for empire state
where spider-man goes to college and the spell
they use to make people forget he calls the runes
of cough call they spend a lot of wandervision
sort of setting up the rules for how runes and
magic work inside the mcu with agatha harkness and
scarlet witch agatha harkness and scarlet witch
use them for defensive purposes doctor strange
is using them as part of this big memory spell
when wong claims that the spell travels the
dark borders of known and unknown reality
the unknown reality that he's talking about is
just the areas of the multiverse that they don't
have a lot of knowledge of the 10 rings of power
are a good example of that like wong says there's
no record of the 10 rings anywhere in kamar taj
and they have records that go back to the dawn of
the multiverse doctor strange explains that the
sanctum was built on top of ancient ruins of a
temple where they performed the spell because this
area is at the intersection of a bunch of ultra
powerful magical ley lines when he says that they
weren't the first ones to try and tap that power
with the sanctums that's a teaser for something
i think that they'll get into with future doctor
strange movies the joke about them shooting the
episode of the equalizer here in the 80s is just
an action thriller series if you've ever lived
in new york city they're always filming tv shows
and movies all over the place borrowing people's
apartments people's houses when peter messes the
spell up doctor strange says he changed it six
times spider-man says he only did it five times
that's a reference to the five sinister six films
in the sixth time i think as a reference to venom
in the post-credits scene and at the end of the
movie when the spell gets even worse when reality
starts tearing all over the place you see those
blue figures show up in the cracks of reality
from other universes most of those characters
are other sinister six spider-man villains like
there's a craven the hunter with a spear a classic
version of scorpion black cat a classic version
of the rhino one of them even looks kind of like
the watcher uwatu from the what if series mostly
other classic spider-man villains though the mit
admissions officer's license plate is a reference
to the amazing spider-man number three published
in 1963 because it was the first appearance of
doctor Octopus and when alfred molina's doctor
Octopus from spider-man 2 shows up he says the
power of the sun in the palm of my hand aligned
directly from spider-man 2 he also repeats that
line when he sees iron man's arc reactor because
the arc reactor itself is very similar to what
he was trying to achieve with his fusion reactor
the nissan license plate is another reference to
an amazing spider-man comic book sinister six team
up foreshadowing the other sinister six characters
later in the movie when he steals spider-man's
iron spider nanites giving himself a temporary
iron man upgrade this is a very meta reference
to the connection between Tobey maguire's doctor
Octopus and mcu iron man in the first iron man
movie kevin feige originally wanted to have iron
man be the person who created Doctor Octopus's
arms like he wanted them to be stark tech but at
the time sony said no dice spider-man then learns
that he can use his ai to take control of Doctor
Octopus's arms there are a lot of Octopus jokes
throughout the movie like spider-man calls it a
tentacle situation and later aunt may asks him if
he Doctorinks salt water because he's an Octopus
when the admissions officer says she's going
to help them all get into mit at the end of
the movie after the second doctor strange spell
that's why both mj and ned leeds get into mit but
peter doesn't because the second spell made her
forget about peter so she and mit never thought
to include him for admission green goblin then
shows up in his full goblin armor from the first
spider-man movie because they were all transported
before they died so presumably he was transported
before his final battle with tobey maguire
and that's why his costume looks all shiny
he gives spider-man's iron spider gauntlet an
upgrade giving it the magic spell to instantly
transport the villains into the holding cells
there are all kinds of jokes about ned leeds
secretly having magical abilities but when doctor
strange jokes at the beginning of the film saying
that he should consult his physician about the
tingling in his hands that's just a joke about ned
maybe having early onset diabetes but legit during
the movie they do clarify ned lee's does have some
magical aptitude because later in the movie doctor
strange confirms did you open these portals and he
says yes and then he gives them a nod like oh
abs pretty cool they also give him the cloak
of levitation briefly later when it saves him from
falling and he says thank you mr cape just teasing
that yes ned could become a sorcerer someday
doctor strange makes his scooby-doo reference go
ahead and scooby-doo this crap when they start
talking about the undercroft the undercroft is
actually a real world term for the crypt of a
church later spider-man also tells them that the
crypt is where the cells are like i said doctor
strange explained the sanctum was built on top of
an ancient temple that's far older in the crypt of
the undercroft is just part of the original temple
but the joke in present day is that in the sanctum
they're just using the undercroft as their regular
basement like they're doing their launDoctory
there when they first walk down there's a bunch of
old board games the goatee template is just a joke
about Doctor strange's goatee there's a pilates
machine that ned thinks is a torture rack there's
a whole model train set just a whole lot of common
regular household items like all their christmas
decorations are up above them mj makes a whole
bunch of doctor strange jokes she calls him Doctor
magic then later also tells the sinister six
villains that they're in the dungeon of a wizard
electro also calls him dungeons and Doctoragons
ned thinks that the lizard is a dinosaur there's a
really quick blink and you'll miss it horror movie
easter egg when spider-man starts trying to clean
his advanced suit with all the cleaning fluid when
he reaches for the solution behind him there's
this old creepy doll that turns its head and looks
at him like the doll is supposed to be alive or
possessed there's a couple easter eggs for things
in real life on mj's phone when they start looking
for the green goblin this person on the glider is
actually a real person who created his own green
goblin style glider with a massive Doctorone then
later there's another green goblin joke when she
pulls up the next picture in its green elf cosplay
because spider-man earlier had told doctor
strange that the other villain he saw looked
kind of like a flying green elf zoom in enhanced
on nedley's laptop he's got a this is fine meme
which is sort of commentary on the plot of the
movie too like everything is on fire this is
all terrible but it's totally fine everything is
fine when he starts reading the eyewitness reports
saying people spotted green goblin at a military
facility attacking that's a reference to the way
they introduced green goblin during the first
tobey maguire spider-man movie one of his first
acts wearing the goblin armor was to attack the
military base then they bring back thomas hayden
church's sandman from spider-man 3 and electro
from amazing spider-man 2. peter says a blue
guy showed up jamie foxx was telling jokes when
he was first cast in the movie saying i'm not
going to be blue in this one there are many many
jokes and references to those classic spider-man
movies throughout the film the way they explain
his yellow lightning in the mcu though is that
electro basically says oh i felt something was
different about the energy of this universe i
like it later when he rigs up the ark reactor
with his harness costume it's meant to resemble
the original electro comic book costume they
even do the electric crown around his head using
his energy when all the sinister six villains come
back into the cells they start recapping the plots
of their original movies joking about how the
lizard try to turn everyone into lizards he offers
to turn electro into a lizard when ned leads asks
if the tree is a scientist who got turned into a
tree or a tree monster of some kind that's just
a groot reference because he is a talking tree
then the way they play norman osborne green goblin
between the different personas is that for most
of this part of the movie he's norman osborne he
smashes the helmet which also kind of sets up him
having the more comic book accurate costume later
in the film he tries to go back to his house from
the tobey maguire spider-man movies we find out
that there is no oz corp in existence in the mcu
he also implies that harry osborne is different
in the mcu because he kind of halfway finishes
a sentence when talking about his son then for
those of you that have been waiting for more x-men
easter eggs in these new marvel phase 4
movies there's a classic x-men symbol in
green paint over spider-man's face on the fee
shelter billboard when he's coming back to see
norman osborne the fee shelters themselves are
right out of the comics feast is an acronym that
stands for food emergency aid shelter and training
but they were created by mr negative in the comics
so maybe they'll introduce a version of him in
spider-man 4 or some future spider-man movie
norman osborne corrects spider-man that it's
Doctor osborne not mr and he confuses mj for
the Tobey version of mary jane because of harry
osborne's relationship with mj that's how he got
to know her the goblin persona doesn't really take
over again until they go back to happy's apartment
when doctor strange brings his box back to
contain the spell the symbol on it is the symbol
of the vishanti it's the same symbol on the eye of
agamotto and the same symbol in the window of the
sanctum the vishanti and the comics are a trio
of cosmic beings that grant Doctor strange the
magical energy that he uses to weave his spells
then for those of you asking how spider-man is
able to keep the box away from him even after he
gets separated into his astral form this is all
because of the way the spidey sense works it's
all about the peter tingle but the spidey sense
is actually like this sixth sense biological
ability that spider-man has and it just allows him
to innately to automatically react to threats so
after doctor strange separates him into his astral
form just like the ancient one did to him and then
to the hulk during avengers end game his body is
automatically reacting to the threat of doctor
strange when he gets the cloak of levitation
that's an easter egg for what if spiderman from
the marvel zombies episode the whole mirror
dimension fight is just a much larger version of
the mirror dimension fight from the first doctor
strange movie they have a couple references to
spider-man 2 with the train fight scene when he
and Doctor strange fight on the subway train that
splits into many different aspects then they have
another sort of spider-man science bros joke when
he defeats Doctor strange's magic using science
defeating him using basic geometry and then
during the end credits with all the graphics
like the hand-Doctorawn graphics they have a
bunch of geometric shapes as a callback to that
when he returns and offers to help the sinister
six green goblin says his iconic phrase from the
first tobey maguire spider-man movie i'm something
of a scientist myself when elektro starts flipping
the tv channels in happy's apartment using his
powers the first image is of the new statue of
liberty with captain america shield foreshadowing
the final boss fight when Doctor Octopus says
spider-man is helping them using scraps from a
bachelor's junk Doctorawer that's a big callback
to the iconic iron man line tony stark built this
in a cave with a box of scraps they start trying
to fabricate fixes for all the villains starting
with the chip that helps control Doctor Octopus's
arms but the goblin ante serum doesn't work until
Tobey maguire's spider-man tunes it just a little
bit electro and sandman bond over their villain
origin stories like they both fell into things
gotta be careful where you fall when he fixes
doctor Octopus the lights on his tentacle arms
change back to white to show you that he's
in control because during spider-man 2 the
lights were always red when the tentacles were in
control he gives spider-man back his iron spider
nanites and they combine with the advanced suit
to create the new integrated suit that's just what
they're calling this version of the suit green
goblin kills aunt may and then as she starts
to die they kind of turn her into a version of
mcu uncle ben giving her the great power great
responsibility speech and this is the first time
that it's ever been uttered out loud in the mcu
green goblin's costume turns into a more comic
book accurate version of his costume he's got
the purple cloak he later gets the pouch and the
strap from the comics as well then they finally
bring back anDoctorew garfield and Tobey maguire
when ned leeds learns that he can open portals
using the sling ring each of them is wearing the
same versions of their spider-man costumes that we
last saw them in but anDoctorew admits that after
gwen stacy died he got super rageful and bitter
more violent more hardcore and Tobey explains that
now he has a family with his mj like i said maybe
if they come back in another multiverse movie like
secret wars they'll have a mayday parker reference
also when they're bringing each of them back like
when they step through the portals they start
playing the theme songs from their spider-man
movies later in the movie michael giaccino remixed
all three of the spider-man theme songs into a new
theme song when they're doing their full science
bros scene they also have a version of this later
during the final boss fight when they're all web
slinging together at the same time on screen when
they all meet they reference losing uncle ben
Tobey says the rest of the line with great power
comes great responsibility anDoctorew explains
what happened to his gwen stacy during amazing
spider-man 2 to set up the scene of him saving
mj from falling later redeeming himself tobey
Maguire tells them about killing the man who
killed uncle ben which sets up the end of the
movie where he stops tom hall and spider-man from
killing green goblin and then they go full team
spider-man science bros because all three of them
are scientists there's a funny easter egg for
james franco's harry osborne and hobgoblin when
nedley's asked Tobey if he had a best friend and
he basically explains the plot of spider-man 3
with the harry osborne goblin later ned tells
peter i'll never turn into a super villain
and try to kill you because that's exactly what
happened in the comics ned leeds becomes a version
of hobgoblin and tries to kill spider-man when he
leaves the message for the world with jay jonah
jameson he calls himself a friendly neighborhood
spider-man anDoctorew garfield also called himself
that too the whole thing with the new statue of
liberty and the captain america shield is you have
to remember this is all happening after falcon has
become the new captain america during falcon and
winter soldier so they're celebrating steve rogers
captain america's legacy what the avengers did
saving the universe in avengers end game and the
passing of the mantle with the shield to falcon
they just referenced it during the hawkeye series
yelena belova telling kate bishop that she wanted
to go visit the new statue of liberty because of
the time jump to christmas at the end of the movie
by that time they finish construction they make a
whole bunch of jokes about Tobey Maguire's organic
web shooters like does it only come out of your
wrists or does it come out of other places as well
when he starts talking about his web block
that's the existential crisis that he had
during spider-man 2 when he couldn't use his
abilities they referenced all the craziest
villains that they faced in tom holland spider-man
tells them about the plot of avengers infinity war
thanos the infinity gauntlet and avengers end
game they also joke that the avengers is a band
like is it a band because the avengers don't exist
in their universes Tobey maguire references venom
also kind of foreshadowing the venom post credit
scene because he says oh i find an alien too he
was a lump of black goo all the scenes of all
three of them together fighting all the witty
banter it's all amazing this is probably one of
my favorite parts of the movie they confirm my
lizard trailer edit theory the mystery lizard
scene of him getting kicked by nothing but air
Doctor Octopus returns to help them which is a
similar twist to the end of spider-man 2 where he
turned good again and helped save the world when
ned leeds accidentally opens the portal for doctor
strange he says he's been dangling over the grand
canyon for 12 hours that's a callback to the loki
joke from thor ragnarok him falling for 30 minutes
when electro chills out talking to anDoctorew
garfield there's a huge miles morales easter egg
he says i always thought that you were black and
this is well maybe there's a black spider-man
out there somewhere they haven't completely
revealed all their plans for mcu miles morales
but he does exist they name Doctorop him during
spider-man homecoming Tobey maguire reunites with
Doctor Octopus saying that he's been trying to do
better because that's something the doctor
Octopus told to him during spider-man 2
anDoctorew garfield saves mj redeeming himself for
not saving gwen stacy and then when spider-man is
fighting green goblin on top of the giant captain
america shield it's meant to be a callback to
his mcu introduction during captain america civil
war with that iconic captain america shield scene
they pay off that tobey maguire scene by having
him stop spider-man from killing green goblin
and then like i said the multiverse villains start
showing up in the cracks of reality all mostly
meant to be other spider-man villains from other
universes like classic craven rhino black cat
scorpion they fix green goblin then perform the
spell sending everyone back and making everyone
forget that he's spider-man in the mcu but i know
there's a lot of questions about what exactly
this changes so it does not erase everything
that spider-man has done because right after
this you hear jay jonah jameson yelling about
spider-man it only erases knowledge of peter
parker the spell also erases all the personal
relationships that peter formed as peter parker
but not the relationships that he formed when he
was wearing the costume in the mask and that's
also the reason why he's got the ged course book
at the end of the film because peter parker was
enrolled at midtown high so by erasing knowledge
of him it means like he was never enrolled there
in the first place but when it's time for avengers
5 and they want to have another big spider-man
crossover he can go re-explain everything to them
again like if he told doctor strange what happened
with the spell doctor strange would probably get
up to speed pretty quickly like okay i get it
mj's joke about figuring out that he's spider-man
all over again it's just foreshadowing i think
for the next spider-man trilogy to them doing
something similar that they did during this first
trilogy she says she figured out his identity
before she can do it again that's kind of what
happened during spider-man far from home the whole
ending scene at aunt may's grave is very similar
to the way they ended a couple the tobey maguire
anDoctorew garfield's spider-man movies a lot of
them had scenes at the ends of their movies
at various points in graveyards happy also
references iron man's death in avengers end game
saying something like this happened with a friend
of mine a little while ago we learned that he's
moved into a tiny dump of an apartment that looks
very similar to the apartment that Tobey maguire
spider-man lived in too bad they didn't bring mr
dikovich back he still needs that rent there's a
new coffee cup meaning that he's continued to go
back to mj's diner after the time jump like it's
a couple months time jump they go from october
to christmas week during december you see that
he's been using a sewing machine to make his
own costume using scraps from the old costume
and new bright blue fabric to make it look more
like the classic comic book costume the sewing
machine is also a callback to spiderman making
his own costume in the comics and Tobey Maguire
anDoctorew garfield's versions both making their
spider-man costumes using sewing machines like i
said they're just taking him back to ground level
being more of a friendly neighborhood spider-man
much less tech Doctoriven much less beholden to
iron man other big avengers characters then he
swings over rockefeller center the ice rink the
christmas tree during christmas week like i said
which overlaps with the plot of the hawkeye series
i've already done a big post credit scene video
for venom so i'll link that at the end of this
and i'll be doing a new doctor strange two trailer
video tomorrow so make sure you have alerts turned
on from my channel so you don't miss that just
to explain the timeline of the eternals movie
too because there's like a giant stone eternal tia
mud in the indian ocean right now that's happening
around the time spider-man no way home is
happening so on the other side of the planet you
just have to picture there's like a giant stone
celestial that just came out of the ocean just as
spider-man is fixing everything with the second
spell if there are any other easter eggs that
you spotted in the movie that i didn't mention in
this video or my previous videos just write them
below in the comments everyone click here for
that spider-man no way home post credit scene
and click here for the doctor strange 2 trailer
i'll update the link as soon as i finish posting
that video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!